seventy to eighty years ago we would
have been in a world war
could you imagine telling someone in the
trenches oh I'm addicted to insulin shot
though you know what I mean
part of me is like we go back to extreme
ownership and personal responsibility
log off sign now I get it elite the app
you enter put a random unit and then the
people who happen to be place near you
in holes
it's literally Susan on a Excel
spreadsheet who randomly the size matter
thing the amount of Susan's or Derek's
that have designed people's best friends
forever
next one availability bias was trying to
we're looking some work and there's some
digestive biscuits in the kitchen and
not it was like digestive biscuit but
retn digestive biscuits every single day
because they just are there in the jar
and yet whatever is available to you
you've got to almost instill willpower
to avoid it which means that given
enough time given enough lack of sleep
given enough XYZ you're probably going
to give in at some point
so yeah design the environments key
the internet goes wild for George McGill
back on modern wisdom it's been a long
time man thank you so much for coming
back it's good to be back you brought me
up a cave it's good I have indeed a lot
has changed since we were last here yeah
a lot a lot has changed for both parties
I imagine
yeah we're changing you're down in
London now you're a Manchester songs
yeah down in London but more expensive
but hmm you get what you pay for
yeah you do a lot of opportunities yeah
it's um it's certainly very very
different there's a really good Paul
Graham essay called cities and ambition
yeah heard of it no it's one of them one
of my favourite ones of his one reason
why I moved and he says that every city
sort of whispers something to you
whether it's this sort of conversations
that you overhear or the people that
you're around or the cars that drive
past are the buildings that you see
you're constantly getting whispered to
and you you don't you don't consciously
notice it but you pick up on it and
because I found that the poor poor Paul
Graham says that New York it's the the
constant whispering is make more money I
mean that's cuz every every conversation
over here so how much money you make you
know I made this this month whereas in
LA it's be more famous it's constantly
whispering to you what London moves well
he says San Francisco is B be more
powerful in terms of they don't give a
[ __ ] if you mean like a billion dollars
up if you've inherited billion dollars
it's more about what you've done with
London is it with the thing about London
is there's almost the little cities of
in little cities but the minute would
been primarily based in Mayfair
have you been to Mayfair before yeah
it's like the it's like the wealthiest
part of like Rhenish the booking and
pilots that Maserati Maserati Atlantic
you so there's a [ __ ] box of course
we go get the most guy for these to get
new car keeping him a guy need to get a
new car I've been drone that box of
courses he done right
try to drive them no I'm Joey from Ren
it's just rent a big dick one rent a
[ __ ] Maserati when you need it yes
instead of being instrument baller so
it's ago so the Internet is ready and
waiting
moist for some more mental models metal
model 101 is the highest performing
episode ever
on modern wisdom massive shout out to
podcast notes for supporting that
episode
I mean who spoke about James clear
replied to some of our tweets to do with
it Navarre I've account got tagged in a
load so we got a little bit of pressure
to make this one not at it but we're
gonna be fine
I've got an absolute ballot to start you
off with let's go this is from Gabriel
Weinberg's big book of mental models
Gabriel if you're listening I know that
you're busy man but I'm ready and
waiting whenever you are and this is a
mental model from tennis okay
the unforced error though okay so the
concept is that you need to focus on
being less wrong not because of an
external situation but because of your
own poor judgment or execution so you
got to think about how making a bad
first impression that's your fault like
if you didn't get ready in sufficient
preparation that's an unforced error
touches a little bit on some of the
asymmetries we were talking about before
you're in a car crash because you were
texting unforced error mm-hmm that
you've caused that situation wasn't
there wasn't some tornado that came out
of somewhere and picked your car up and
threw to one side this was an error that
you caused so you were talking
previously about not aiming to be right
all the time just simply avoiding being
wrong and then an unforced error is the
most basic way that you can be wrong but
independent of all of the circumstances
you don't [ __ ] up and isn't the
argument that I forgot either doing the
complete tennis metaphor but the
amateurs make way more unforced errors
than professionals or it's not along
those languages so yeah this is an
interesting one that kind of ties into
probably the hardest concepts I wrap
your head around you've heard about
chakra willing so extreme ownership
where you just take ownership of every
single thing that goes on in your life
and it's always you know the famous good
run worries but he's one of those one of
the best videos on YouTube if you
haven't liked a [ __ ] day I recommend it
it's just this the hardest Navy SEAL
he's like the heart
he's like the hard maybe SEAL amongst
hard Navy since you don't know where
it's made to go [ __ ] at he's intense
yeah so he's that guy
the was the Bradley Cooper film the
American sniper yeah so Jocko I think
was that guy's like commander
essentially or one the boss and he's
talking about when he was in Iraq and
people would come over to him and say
hey boss we've not got enough of
machinery or we've not got expose aired
or things gone wrong and he would just
always reply with good no matter what
because opportunity to work on this or
opportunity to do that and it's always
something that he can control and he's
obsessed with this concepts of extreme
ownership and he tells I think it's in
his TED talk and in his book where he
talks about because he's very it's very
well to a chat in I get a nice little
podcast about oh I've been doing X Y Zed
on my gym routine you know meditation
but when you're at war I have so much
more respect for somebody when they if
they're talking about interesting
concepts I think oh I applied this at
war I got oh okay I might listen that
because I get my ring yeah I think
that's literally the [ __ ] terrain
right is literally well Joe's knee-deep
yeah thanks down in terrain yeah so he's
up to his knees in terrain yeah so um he
talks about how in Iraq where you got
where he says that he had some friendly
fire go wrong and it was his in his
troops that happened and I think it was
an Iraqi soldier lost their life because
his foot sort of friendly Iraqi troops
firing back at his own American troops
and somebody died and his hired Navy
SEAL that's one of the worst mistakes
you can ever make and the reason he
ended up keeping his job is because he
took 100 percent blame over
Finley was so impressive how he managed
to just take extreme ownership over it
and it wasn't even you cannot he wasn't
even his fault like he he wasn't
directly there but he said I ain't
there's certain things we could have
done there's certain things I could have
prepared for and you think about how
much I do all the time like a little
stuff where I'll be running late and
I'll blame on someone you know you mean
you've blame it on something else and
again at the concepts of extreme
ownership of everything that can go
wrong is ultimately my fault and even
when it's not it's sometimes still helps
to think that do you what I mean there's
so many stuff like where if you act
let's say you have to I always go back
to the fourth experiment of two
identical versions of yourselves the one
that takes extreme ownership over
everything would just always outperform
the one who didn't right but what Jordan
Peterson's main stick been for the last
couple of years
rights versus responsibilities he says
you have two choices either nothing
matters or everything matters and if you
choose to say that everything matters
then you don't get to use the excuse
that it was someone else's fault
it is always something that is within
your control
and this touches on another point jaakor
willing mental model of you haven't done
yet anti fragile yeah that's that comes
from NASA Nutella NASA and Talib who
wrote the Black Swan fooled by
randomness and a few other interesting
concepts and the idea of antifragility
is let's say for example you have quite
let's say you look to this like glass
here this is by a very niche as we just
found out in the kitchen earlier we use
and smash the glass everywhere and I
just put my head on so the kitchen yeah
behind the scenes that will never get
released yeah if you drop this on a
concrete floor or a kitchen floor as we
saw then it's fragile barriers for very
nature in that when this order happens
the whole thing basically disintegrates
that's something that's fragile when
disorder occurs it breaks down the
contrast to that is what's one owners
robust which is when you drop it on the
floor like a plastic cup in sort of
stays the same he doesn't get worse it
also doesn't get better
so what Talib's sort of identified it
there's nothing that's truly the
opposite of fragility because robust
isn't the opposite of fragility cuz it's
changing sale there - one to zero
exactly whereas the plus one would be
something that's anti fragile that it
gets stronger from disorder so the most
obvious examples your immune system that
you give it a little bit of tuberculosis
and all of a sudden oh it knows it gets
used to dealing with that and now it's
much better at dealing with that whereas
if you if you prevent a child from sort
of playing around in the mud and
damaging a little bit of its immune
system each time you never grow if you
never exercise and put your body under
stress you never grow so your body's
almost an anti fragile machine in the
the more disorder you give it the more
it adapts of course it has a breaking
point where you go you can overstep the
marker and you break your legs or
whatever you do but while you catch
tuberculosis yeah so there has to be a
locus but the concept of anti fidelity
is an interesting one because you see
all the time where you see two people go
through very very similar events and
some people say that's the best thing
that ever happened to them and then
compound as a result and they use that
and then other people who did the exact
same thing it's that the worst thing
that ever happened to them and yeah I
think becoming more anti fragile is it's
difficult but it's um summer I need to
get better ice something that was very
very difficult today I think so so some
of the ideas that comes to mind I saw a
tweet earlier on hilarious tweet
someone's five-year-old child had said
to his mother the reason he wasn't
cleaning my room was because it was good
for his immune response any like Joshua
why haven't you clean your room it's
good for my immune immune systems
[ __ ] you Joshua got a five-year-old
busted so one really good practical
example I heard came from Josh wolf who
he's the founder of the looks capital
very very very clever guy he has quite a
few mental models we can go on too but
he talked about when he was decided to
invest in a certain company which was
nuclear cleanup so click cleaning up
Wailord waste essentially and he
realized that it was an anti fragile
decision in the sense that no matter
what chaos occurred it was upside for
him because let's say for example the
world carried on investing heavily in
nuclear waste well at one point there's
going to be an accident which means that
there's gonna be neat when you can clean
up or if the world decides you know what
we need less nuclear activity therefore
they need the nuclear clear-up company
however so and as a result obviously
Fukushima happened he made a lot a lot
of money if you've wrapped ready for
yeah he was the only company that could
deal with that and I only did he make a
lot of money but he saved so much damage
college as well survives so that's like
that's a good example of where you apply
it to to business in particular as are a
couple of good examples here where
antifragility is being applied in an
athletic sense and you can take this and
adopt it for yourself in a very personal
sense katrin davidsdottir CrossFit
athlete one of the fits women on the
planet was the fittest woman on the
planet a couple of times I remember
seeing an interview with her as a part
of Ben Bergeron's chasing excellence
fantastic book highly recommended if
you've not read it very easy very
narrative based quick read and she says
sometimes when people haven't had enough
sleep or they haven't prepped right for
a day's training they go into the gym
and they've got a defeatist mentality
and they say well I'm not feeling very
good I'm tired I'm this on that and the
other whereas she goes in and her
mentality is this is an opportunity for
me to train at so optimal preparation of
scenario so this is the CrossFit Games
last year they didn't know but they just
got pulled out and put on the wedding
stay they didn't know there was gonna be
a wedding stay event out of nowhere then
on the flight back the plane was delayed
everybody was like everyone was gonna
get less sleep for the next day and that
was the one day that they were supposed
to recover and blah blah blah all of
that she is preparing herself for that
she leans into she calls it leaning into
discomfort as if you've invited it
through the door so she doesn't shy away
from it the same as if you put your hand
on somebody's chest and you press
they press back you press a bit harder
and they press back a little bit more
and that's the kind of mindset that
she's cultivated you might want to talk
about the it was the guy from Josh
Waitzkin Josh Waitzkin and his reframing
of his child's ring oh yeah that's one
my favorite ones of them I always think
about when I do have a kid to touch boy
someday not someday soon too
but again that'll bite me in the ass yes
not the course or lessons you want to
apply and I think obviously everybody's
almost playing this weird quite meta
Darwinian game obviously they're
literally passing on their parents DNA
by the by the nature about nobody's
passing on their parents DNA and then
they're passing on their parents DNA but
you're also kind of passing on okay what
was the stuff that my parents did right
what did I like about it obviously you
need to do a little I Oh s update for
the current generation because obviously
these things weren't around by then so
now you gotta think of smartphone
policies right but you try and take what
your parents did right and then what you
parents could have or should have done
as well and imagine of ideas as yeah and
the better childhood you have the the
more the less stuff that you have to
change you just need to copy and paste
over and a mini ops he looked at ideas
in here from other parents or other
parenting stuff and I've not really gone
deep down the parenting ramble yet again
for hopeful for a while but he talks
about how when he his son was very very
young first few years of his life the
first thing that parents will do to
change the locus of control of a child
and it's not a conscious thing it's very
very subconscious and it's the moment
it's one of the most consistent
conversations you ever hear certainly I
don't know about other countries but
particularly in the UK of the
conversation like the weather where it's
or weather is nice to those and then it
was catch greatness like this which but
rarely happens over here it's a where
was miserable today at yeah the
weather's
and he noticed that parents would
constantly have this conversation with
their kids whereas if the weather was
bad outside
therefore I we should feel a bit rubbish
and we should just stay in and play
board games and he realized that that is
one of the first moments that a kid gets
conditioned to have this low locus of
control and what he did instead is flip
it on its head
which is whenever it's pissing it down
outside oh look at how beautiful it is
and you can argue if you fall right
there's rain coming down the storms and
this fonder so the perspective is it
definitely is beautiful and let's go out
and play in the rain and then you
condition the mind that oh must
everybody else gets really upset about
this moment this is actually a moment to
truly experience and appreciate and I
tried like now when it's raining I catch
my back that's when the metaphors that
stuck in my head for the longest because
even it's raining now I'll get my
clothes ok first start it's not that bad
Ricky it's not that bad and yeah and if
you just say good and I know I look like
a psychopath because there's people in
the rain one couple at that and I'm
[ __ ] buzzes - I've got that metaphor
in my head yeah and it took those parts
of the Joker willing glue fingers well
when everything's going so this is a
weird one I've tried to practice a
little bit of layers when everything's
going bad I say good and when
everything's going good as I say bad
because I know that some psychics
psychologically uh sometimes take my I
might take my foot off the gas so you
stood in the rain like the guy at the
end of Shawshank Redemption crawling out
of the pipe of [ __ ] look you know he's
being like yeah basically okay yeah I'm
just talking about that bad news that oh
you girlfriends just broke me am i cute
good opportunity to it she was a [ __ ]
but yes focus spend more time with
yourself but there wins fur oh just just
made a hundred million pounds of bad you
might lose your own [ __ ] you don't mean
you've got a constantly have that to to
fact-check yeah some weird Zen paradox
gang on the constant player another
great example actually from a podcast
earlier this year with Alex Hutchinson
who wrote the book in June so this is
the definition of a key fragile as far
as I'm concerned
he's got a leak performing athletes of
varying degrees on the top and sat on a
bike doing a video to max test they got
a face mask on which is controlling the
air in and out of their lungs and these
guys are doing maths questions on an
iPad while they're doing it so there are
a fairly high heart rate they're
completing these massive questions on
the iPad on the bike so they don't
actually need to think much it's not a
cognitively demanding task to exercise
like to just turn it but it is a
cognitively demanding task they've got
on the screen in front of them then they
start to push the heart rate a little
bit high a little bit higher and get
them really quite far up into the high
percentages of their max then they
restrict the air through the mask so
that it's like breathing through a straw
breathing at altitude and the absolute
best performers obviously a lot of
people their cognition drops they're
distracted they feel uncomfortable the
absolute best performers get better at
their maths problems when they restrict
the air through the mouth because that's
when they start to lean in to that
disconfirm as if they've invited it
through the door mmm
I just I love love that that whole
concept you told me that story the first
time I'm Santa hairs is standing up on
my arms I'm like [ __ ] that's so cool
these guys are in there at the peak of
discomfort and then someone turns the
discomfort more and they go good that's
why I'm here and that's why I'm here to
do then you just think that is the
difference another perfect example we
talked about passion in life Steffi Graf
one of the greatest tennis players of
all time gets tested at 12 years old as
part of I think she's German part of the
German youth tennis program they test
her and they're testing all of the
athletes on two broad domains first one
is skill mechanical skills second one is
passion and inspiration to train and she
scores 10 out of 10 on both of them so
it's like good [ __ ] luck trying to
beat her like not only is she more
talented than you but she will outwork
you and it won't even feel like work to
her
what she creates individual like that
it's like it's a perfect it's so many
there's so many stuff in the algorithm I
definitely find the biggest influence in
my output general awareness and that's
the correct way yeah I think I just say
output and the way I think is film
around I don't know that sounds [ __ ]
cliches I might hear some Tony Robbins
seminar you just have to get new friends
but but when you I just find I always
use this for experiment of pick the
purse pick imagine you again identical
but we tweak two variables in these two
parallel universes one where you spend
the most amount of time or the person
you spend the most amount of time with
is the person you know whether you know
them in your actual real life or you
know them by it you follow on Instagram
you stream on YouTube who is the most
positive or has the best output work
ethic the way they think that you truly
admire your around that individual the
most less you have them okay guy like
David Hawkins he's just constantly like
going making oh yeah you've got that guy
versus the everyone has one in their
Friendship Circle just the swath you
know mean he's constantly going
oh he's not actually that good is only
because users or the rubbish that sort
of individual he's calms you when you
fix Minds when you one still makes deals
and you feel like you've got an illness
you got [ __ ] I'm slower I'm fatigued
i life is worse as a result of that
individual and the imagine you spend
again the exact same in your DNA your
genetics your your situation one way you
spend it with the the best person one
will you spend it with the worst person
and after a year those two people as in
your two opposing selves in these two
universes so make some rick and morty
[ __ ] happens and you [ __ ] meet one
another those are two different people
very much slave but it's a difficult man
like you are so much less in control of
the people that you're around than you
are of yourself
and I think that what do you mean well I
can't tell you let's say that I spend
every day with you for the next year I
can't tell you how to be I can choose
who I choose to go yeah but I have a
limited number of people that I can
choose to be with I don't know everybody
I don't know who is necessarily good for
me it takes me time to work out who's
toxic and who's not I also think that
it's hard making friends when you're
older that's true I'm thinking Fred no
one ever talks about this because it
sounds like some sort of like weird
autistic social lapper [ __ ] but it's
true it's really how it is like no one
ever wants to say I wish I had some new
friends I'm 25 30 35 40 years old be
really cool if I had some new friends or
some different friends and you think
well hang in a second
people say all the time that they would
love a partner they can be single and
love to have a partner that was like X
and Y and Zed but we just assumed that
the social circle that we're in will
have people come and go like the [ __ ]
tide and we'll pick up some random ones
but what we talking about on the last
one the most valuable asset of the 21st
century as far as you were concerned hi
agency and I agency people will seek out
those friends you know who I think's
mega-mega hi agency person David Parral
David prale told me on a podcast he
actively seeks out spending time with
influences off Instagram spending time
with comedians spending time with
intellectuals he's always the dumbest
person in the room in one of multiple
domains and he keeps changing the domain
you know I can you imagine what David
[ __ ] perrales phone books like Neil
deGrasse Tyson like you know it's just
you know the weirdest form that comes to
the social stuff is that it happens
really early on that these weird look at
the dyes like the classic example is in
university or college when people you
end up at a random uni sometimes you can
choose that one you stand up there and
then the people who happen to be placed
near you in holes and you actually it's
literally
on an Excel spreadsheet who randomly the
size matter thing the amount of susan's
or dare attics that have decided
people's best friends forever and they
automatically assume that all we should
have been best friends but I always use
this example so one cool mental model to
follow because this then goes down a
relationship tangent but if you look at
and this comes from Josh wolf earlier
with the anti fragility stuff is he has
this great mental model of the
directional arrows of progress where if
you look at the computer in the 1950s it
was the size of probably the house that
were in now in a university where there
was maybe only a limited amount of them
in the world and very very few people
could use them and then as decades go on
and you get to nearer the the 70s you
have the home computer and all of a
sudden it's got smaller in size and but
it's cheaper and it's more powerful and
then you get the laptop which we have
here in the the few decades gone by then
the next few decades you get the
smartphone it's even more smaller it's
even more compact and now it sits in
your pocket and now you look at now you
got the air pots that now sit in your
ears so you see these directional arrows
of progress and I know the Tobii look
you the Shopify CEO has a similar thing
when he's trying to analyze future
trends of following this direction arrow
of progress so you you can't predict the
future but you can assume computing as
we know it or hardware as we know it
will continue to get smaller more
powerful cheaper and nearer to our
bodies and obviously everybody talks
about the contact lens that's coming or
whatever it's going to be and I always
apply this with relationships in the if
you looked at our maybe
great-great-great grandparents
generation where you would you might
marry well if you guys same you go back
to hunter and gatherer times you might
just marry whoever you got assigned to
in the tribe or whoever you have to
fight Dave and see what happened or
fight Jets and see what happen and then
obviously you go to our grandparents
time where you would literally if you
wasn't married by eighteen or twenty-one
or whatever that little age window was
you as an outcast and you would meet
someone from your school or your
next-door neighbor but that was it you
ready someone from your school or your
next one
but who's it going to be so you have 15
people to choose from here and then
obviously you have women coming into the
workplace and you have the feminism
movement and people would sort of delay
marriage a little bit then you had a
wider choice you'd maybe meet people at
work or you might meet them at bar and
then you have OkCupid that comes along
so now you can meet people online but it
tends to be a bit of an older
demographic then you have tinder that
comes along and there's more and more
choice and you can got you can meet
random people now I know more and more
couples who are from different countries
and go how will often would that have
happened yeah fifty years ago like that
is such a recent thing of the amount of
kids that are going to be born who won't
be Jul nationality so you're looking at
the direction eras of progress there of
more choice more people you're dating
you get to get more and more resources
and there's a a novel called after on
great podcast as well read yeah have you
listened to after on yeah at the book
yep
oh no no sorry not the book but the
podcast really good fantastic so he has
a scene a bit he writes in that where
the AI gets so good that it matches it's
like a imagine tinder but it's an AI
that sorts it for you and picks a
perfect person based off your interest
their personality the way you like
someone to look on the way that person
likes someone to look because you
realize there's probably a thousand
people out there who would be the best
relationship you could ever imagine a
moment and you've got to think 99.999%
of Asian shapes this sounds really an
awful thing to say but aren't probably
the best relationship for that
individual if you look it's different
maybe a completely objective so many
simulations running at once we sell on
the nearest best thing basically baby
it's getting bare but you're looking at
direction of it's not least it's not
your school your next-door neighbor you
know I mean it's just getting better but
you can imagine a scenario in the future
where everybody meets that truly purpose
individual orient if that exists so be
the intro thats what Rob leads
hypotheses is anyway I like it
next one availability bias oh yeah this
is one as a hilarious example how about
this one which is I when back when was a
social chain
they have a Harry Potter fan page is
like the biggest Harry Potter community
in the world I'm not a Harry Potter fan
at all but I was trying to do this
morning meditation habit and I went
upstairs in one of the rooms trying to
had to take that to do this in the
middle of the room and I've seen I think
I saw the first two Harry Potter's and I
get to you know how before our
generation it was such a big thing I
couldn't give a [ __ ] but Harry Potter
I've got a good friend how many loves
Harry Potter sisters are you gonna hate
me for that but could you give a [ __ ]
about Harry Potter and i sat there
meditating I just observed my own force
and I remember I just catch myself maybe
five minutes saying now go I wonder how
Hermione and Ron felt about Harry being
the face a good one come back to your
breathing come back to your breathing
and then I go oh no it's like being
Daniel Radcliffe and that famous I must
have been crazy being that famous they
can go come back to you okay rolling
managed to get it out and I remember it
a closed meditation assuming I fought
more about Harry Potter in the last
twenty minutes then I had in my entire
life just because there's a [ __ ]
Harry Potter do so and if I live so
where the minute I'm trying to we're
looking at some work and there's some
digestive biscuits in the kitchen and
not others like digestive biscuit but
retn digestive biscuits every single day
because they just are there in the jar
the secret jar and yet whatever is
available to you you've got to almost
instill willpower to avoid it which
means that given enough time given
enough lack of sleep given enough XYZ
you're probably going to give in at some
point
so yeah design the environments key
there's a really good example again
Gabriel Weinberg Sarah Lichtenstein to
study where people rust about 41 leading
causes of death and they massively
overestimated the risk of
sensationalized types so tornadoes
floods botulism or smallpox vaccines
were 50 times overestimate
and stroke and diabetes were a hundred
times underestimated interesting because
the availability bias of the news and
that links in to fill the bubble of
course which is like a echo chamber that
occurs due to this availability bias
that's reinforced by the algorithms that
we see online because what you agree
with you will tend to click on more
which then reinforces feeding you more
of this stuff because the system thinks
oh he's clicking on that therefore he
wants to see more of that
but as jordan peterson says be friends
with people that want the best for you
doesn't mean with be friends but with
people who tell you what you want to
hear very different the kid always want
sweets doesn't mean the kid that sweets
is always good for the kid mmm
so the system constantly feeding you
things that you agree with isn't
necessarily the best for you but the
issue with that and i have this is that
how do you then go about fixing this
problem of social media and we sort of
see somebody knows it's based quite well
that people will insist on okay well
will facebook needs to change its
algorithms where it gives people content
they don't receive but then the wind
spend time on the platform so exist i'm
looking at if you look at Mark
Zuckerberg they're kind of getting
decisions a little bit and I look at it
and go because you've seen the the
recent news about the the American
Center where they want to basically have
it installed in the app that once
somebody scrolled so much they get cut
off this is some weird George Orwell
sure and you know it's Nancy from
Florida who who's heard about Instagram
in an article and histories trying to
enforce or if we're not mainly on what's
up yeah that exact solution yet but I
agree I've embraced a bit and I fought
this there's two ways to potentially fix
this problem first one is that instead
of trying to fix a a heroin problem look
at the needles so instead of trying to
stop the heroin going around the social
media [ __ ] let's look at the needles
which is the smartphones the the put an
app Instagram Facebook snapchat etc and
never gonna fix the problem because that
will come on system second but there
that's their incentives that's their
business model they're never gonna stop
doing it
McDonald's artless that's something kale
I'm surely hard but it was a horrific I
was you did it for a PR bid but they're
never gonna be there full products of
kale it's gonna be greasy fries and
greasy burger because that's what people
go there for and that's what they're
incentivized to do and that's what their
business model is so instead the people
who have the power are Apple and Google
who've got an Android obviously so what
you need to do they've recently released
a screen time stuff but why isn't it
that people can't let's say you flip but
any ultimate judo move where you flip
social media all the mental models of
social media have about the way they've
conditioned people on its head and with
the screen time stuff you create a
social network what I can see out of my
friends who spent the most amount of the
least amount of time on Instagram in its
ranks with them at the top of the
leaderboard and that would be quite a
cool feature and then the final one that
they should do is if it's decide if it's
to settle what I think they should do is
if it's decided that these things are
bad for people's mental health
okay well let's tax them five percent or
ten percent ever that tax is agreed to
be which will be billions of dollars and
instead of focusing it on government
bodies that have to clear what they're
gonna do just do an X Prize we're okay
whichever top twenty entrepreneurs come
up with a solution that's falsifiable by
science in terms of helping people
mental health they get the funding they
get the funding and you filter the money
away from these things that are gonna be
damaging people's mental health into
these companies and and then you
Facebook apparently a facebook Instagram
from Caribbean Instagram snapchat and
Caribbean snapchat but people have the
control in terms of they can customize
their own screen time way more play
games that way and the money's getting
filtered into these mental health
startups I like the analogy about the
needle and the and the drug is it's the
delivery mechanism isn't it through the
phone I would love to see the relative
time on-site desktop versus mobile now
because I think previously the last time
I checked is at 85% mobile I bet that's
even gone up mm-hmm about that's got
Amara it's like ninety ninety five
percent and that's not to say that the
desktop version of the apps isn't that
good it's just that the mobile version
is so overwhelmingly addictive yeah and
convenient that people can't get it this
is my thing about the sort of
anti-social
network is what it needs it means that
again happy ourself as most my stuff
these are naming stuff but basically
what so a lot of the social networks do
is almost have these takes our
relationships and puts them in this
weird little digital stuff this little
hierarchy going on whereas being on
Instagram for five hours a day if you
heard someone if you watch me doing
that's quite a sad thing and if that was
in the leaderboard you go oh and Dave
knew that everyone else was looking when
you spent five hours on Instagram to
know you actually like a bit of loser
you want you don't like and you can put
you can actually use the biases that
these social media outlets have used on
the whole of humanity upside and just
full-on judo move you use the momentum
against them yeah
there's an interesting app I can't
remember the name of that I'll find it
and put it in the show notes where you
pick a time that you're not going to be
on your phone fault and it plants a tree
and the longer time that you know you're
not going to be on for the bigger the
tree grows and you add friends kinda
like a game social networking game and
then if you pick your phone up during
the time you promised you weren't going
to be on it you tree dries mmm your dead
tree and it's a game between you and
your friends to see who can get the
biggest orchard okay and it's all
animated and the trees look cool and a
Christmas have changed into Christmas
trees so that's kind of similar to what
you're talking about that but you're
right I don't know there needs to be
some real innovation when it comes to
the problem of social media at the
moment because it's getting to that
stage now where I think it's a little
bit more than just people looking at it
and going oh that's an interesting
problem people spent too much time on
their phones you've got children growing
up now who've got iPads at two years old
what does that actually do when you've
got someone who is conditioned to a
screen this far from their face with the
dopamine drops that you get and most
people aren't potentially going to be
armed with 74 minute long blog posts
like some of the stuff that gets posted
in the modern wisdom in a circle that's
how to reduce notifications turn your
screen grayscale like all this sort of
stuff that's a lot of time from a young
age to be conditioned to something that
we've never
ever had before you were discussing
earlier on what would happen if someone
did MDMA twice a week for an entire year
what would that do to the synapse is in
their brain well what does it do to
someone's brain who's using this sort of
technology from you and I know you're a
tech optimist so yeah like cuz I always
think it's so easy with a lot of this
stuff to focus on the negatives because
they're so overwhelming but let's look
at how many people have become
millionaires or being able to run their
own business because of these these
platforms let's look at how many people
likes I think 70% and this is completely
a start I've overheard someone else say
but I managed to run about that of
something like 70% of relationships and
now our onions and I start on the
Internet the amount of whatsapp group
chats I think it's a crazy start which
is the age of people coming out of the
closet homosexual people are gay or
lesbian or whatever them no identify us
is significantly gone down because they
can find similar examples like them and
join a reddit community around Atlanta
it's all great I mean it's Grindr but
what but so I'm just going to hold on we
was talking earlier about grinder
grinder yeah because obviously we say no
at the South Pier does look like a dad a
film set but Chris is casting couch but
basically what we're saying earlier is
70 to 80 years ago forgot that right
yeah roughly more roughly conscription
yeah we we would have been in a world
war in the trenches and realistically we
probably would have died or would have
sins stuff that if I would have sinned a
film of right now I'd probably be still
having nightmares of it 12 months later
okay could you imagine telling someone
in the trenches
oh I'm addicted to insulin shot though
you know what I mean I guess I have a
part of me is like we go back to extreme
ownership and personal responsibility
log off so now I get it
the app I get if you're underage and
that sort stuff yes that's a different
question but what we seem as a our
condition as humanity so this is one of
my mental models that fought about a lot
which is I call it design Selma's so
it's a crossover of the current
zeitgeist and out silent so we kind of
forget we kind of every generation
assumes that their problems are the
worse there is and forgets about the
fact that we are just a at the link in
humanity's history but we're also
connected to all these previous
generations and we don't really realize
it and our generation is chatting about
social media addiction whereas I think
it was my great granddad ware who was a
doctor my dad was saying and he was he
was World War one I forgot which battle
line it was that and so many people
dying on the battlefield he ran out and
was just rescue and bodies for hours and
hours and N and I'm [ __ ] complaining
about Instagram stories
I don't so what I think you've got to
take a wider frame on this of course
there's some stuff we can do and we can
look at the X PRIZE as we stuff you
mentioned earlier but come on cuz even
if we fix the Instagram problem people
start moaning about smells I know I'm
sounding like a 50s dad right now I
don't mind I get it man so I mean first
off I think you need to be careful
because everything that you say will be
used on the Internet and if you don't
continue to brand well sites Elmer's
we're me to meet sounds like sparkling
water it's going to be quoted by people
on the internet so guys it's a market in
a horrific way yeah anybody who wants to
rebrand some of Georgie's mental models
please for the love of God get in touch
because they're terrible but yeah I get
what you mean I had a brief discussion
with Theo and Eve from social chain the
same day that we had our mental models
wanna want you in that discussion I said
exactly the same thing as you however as
society progresses the fidelity and
resolution with which we look at our
well-being has to advance as well it's
no good saying a hundred years ago you'd
have been in the trenches because it is
not a hundred years ago the advancement
of well-being of humanity as a whole
requires us to continue to look at this
with a finer and finer viewpoint we need
to continue okay
because it's not as bad as it was
doesn't play again that I desi can maybe
at that yeah and it's a I I get what you
mean I do I preach is somewhere between
I think what we're both overs are saying
there's some happy medium there I think
like a slightly tangent note that as
society continues progressing because we
facing a few now too much too abundance
that's what all our problems are we've
got too much information about too much
food that's making us fat you know me
we've got too many things going on
life's too good that as a result we're
kind of like a heroin addicts who's got
everything constantly getting everything
as result ends up feeling nothing and I
think that we'll see richer and richer
sres society gets richer and richer
people start paying weirdly for negative
experiences you see it and I would like
the likes of Treasury how big people
like half marathons and I'm seeing
marathons more and more meditation
retreats and ultimately I think I'll
make would it come down to a scenario
where I had was wondering would I pay
for this of where imagine a crazy VR
scenario where I could go and be for
five minutes see what it was really like
isolationist I said yeah no but I ii see
what it was like in the trenches and I
could see that and I go oh and I take
that off and there's a resort go massive
contrast to the last one it's so good
but life is so good I could have been
fighting a war and we don't we forget
how I gave up my sound like Tony Robbins
here we forget and I'm don't doubt me
before Tony but we forget how bad it's
been for our so much of human history
because the issue is everyone else's
around user born now so you know you
don't get to see Dave from the trenches
we go how do you day meant you guys I've
just been here echo chamber availability
bias contrast but that's why I say the
most important thing on this sort of VR
front to watch my favorite clip of all
time everybody who I sent it to you guys
it's changed me it's the best like three
minutes Lloyd it yeah right if Roy from
Rick and Morty in the show notes below
I'm gonna watch it fantastic those don't
go back to the carpet stores also do not
go back to the carpet store I actually
so one of the things you might do this
it's not in mind new places when is it
Manchester's a bull my on the wall above
where I got changed is Roy falling off
in the final scene when he falls off
breaks his back and dies and it's the
Roy school all over yeah and I catch
myself playing that Tim herb and talks
about this from wait but why and you go
realistically this is just a video game
like what we're playing is just a video
game
what are you right and this sounds
really weird but you just wait you just
born one day and you're this shaven
chimp and you take carried up on an
iPhone and I do desert and then any just
you die and it's depending on I guess
your original stuff but I'd say you just
die and it's like the overall you know
you certainly won't remember much in the
next slide which is just a video game
and I think what's your not Roy clip
quite regularly everyone who watches
occur that's what was I think it would
just playing a game of Roy mmm-hmm so
right for the people that listening Roy
is seen from Rick and Morty Morty goes
into a virtual reality game where he's
born becomes an NFL player live the life
of this guy called Roy then he dies at
the end comes back out but he's lived
this whole life right comes back out and
Rick then does a like analysis of how he
playing it how he played the game and it
you totally right it is that the ability
to view things with that broad
perspective and to take yourself out of
this situation is a big part of it so
what I want to move on to is I can't
remember what we did last time but let's
quickly go through
hanlin's razor Occam's razor and then
let's do McGill's razor yet again
internet if we can find something to
rebrand it with them
oh please feel free so I guess Occam's
razor is probably the most like well
known one from philosophy of if in doubt
you go with the if you're presenting
with two similar arguments and you can't
make your mind up on which one you go
with the most simplest solution or you
the reason why we've got a razor is
because you lean towards it people often
I think and again I don't know this well
enough that people often thing
No therefore the simpler solutions
always the answer no no no you assume
the simplest solution is the answer but
then you work from there you look for
counter evidence etc but you assume that
whereas Hanlon's raises another version
of that where if your possess a
somebody's pissed you off and you have
equal evidence where the out of malice
or was it out of them not just thinking
you're not attribute to malice what can
be afforded to stupid it's exactly so
Hanlan's razor is just assumed that it
was down to the stupidity or it was down
to their language thinking it wasn't
because they're a bad person and then
the razor I have is if presented with
two situations
choose the one and that will bring about
the most amount of look and I'd say this
is if I had to give I always say every
episode had to pick one minute or one of
them pick a different on each [ __ ]
episode well that's fine but this I
guess it is as I get older these things
change and I'd say in terms of actual
output towards me and what I do and I
God I don't have done anything
particularly special yeah or in general
in that this one here by far has the
most amount of impact so I'll get I'd
even like more practical examples of
this so quite recently a guy was
messaging me and we supposed to go for
drinking he was that I she'll be good
I should be go for a drink tonight what
should we delay and I was that good a
[ __ ] caught myself and I was getting
what's gonna bring about the most look
here me going and sitting at home and
just chilling out and doing nothing or
going for a drink or like minded guy
I've never met before and see what
happens and of course I was like oh
definitely the latter is but even though
naturally I was going I'm tired I want
to go home is that okay let's just put
the luckiest option as a result lots of
stuff came off the back of that and
constantly looking for where okay I've
got two potential decision trees to go
down here which one do I think it's
gonna bring about the most amount of
look and constantly doing that well my
favorite examples is my mate Sir James
and Rhys where they were a great concept
and then the M en
that those two guys have massive drag
fans and they were both in the toilet
someone make James is proper into like
sneakers he's on the sneak ads and he
sees a massive guy at him in the toilets
and he says may I love your shoes and
you just just randomly complements a
stranger and they get trapped under
penis checking penis in anything the
whole the the CrossFit one hands on each
other is a quality course and bill not
to a point that but I say yeah they say
complimenting money shoes and they get
chatting back and forth anyway that guy
turned out to be Drake's DJ and he was
trying to come back the IP movers and
hang around with Drake and Kevin de
Bruyne and poor pauper and Odell Beckham
jr. and they went out with like the
a-list of the a-list at the ends I'm not
saying that stomach you want to aspire
to but that's a [ __ ] cool story right
and a great night and as a result
whenever Drake comes the time they text
that DJ and he sorts them out thinking
that just came down to complement the
guy in his shoes I know but let's say
you were sat there and sometimes people
don't want to chat to me strange or
certainly don't a compliment stranger
but what's gonna bring about the most
amount a look me just keeping that for
in my head just not gonna bring about
that much look whereas if I go hey mate
like this did it of course he might say
alright make just by be a dick you've
not lost anything but the potential
amount of look that's constantly exist
and I always think about it and you only
see this stuff backwards is that you
know the whole
sliding doors phenomenon where you look
back in you go oh if I would have gone
out that night where I ended up meeting
this would about the mother of my kids
yeah imagine if I would have just gone
an hour said I'm a night so we're
constantly having these sliding doors
might even there's whip chatting right
now the sliding doors moments going on
but you don't see them at the time you
can only see them looking backwards so
the sliding doors are invisible when you
go through them but constantly visible
when you look back yeah and I think the
only really save so much it comes down
to look there for just having some
default raises in place okay what often
it's gonna bring about the most not a
look here and just doing that is
something I'm trying to get better
anyway I think it's a really it's
something that I'm thinking about a lot
after the podcast I did with Laura van
de Kamp which I thought was really
insightful
if you haven't listened to yeah I highly
recommend that you go and see it time
management expert and she talks about
the fact that the present self is
spoiled like a pet
child we have three selves in this life
the future self the past itself in the
present self but as you've said when the
present self comes around you're
actually thinking I'm tired it's cold
outside I've had a long day I've done
this that and the other staying in bed
and reading or watching Netflix or not
doing the thing which involves more
action your body will always resort to
inertia or the path of least resistance
over that of one which requires more
effort and I think seeking out going
back to what we were talking about
before extreme ownership leaning into
discomfort all of these things are
gelling together in a way that I think
actually better the mental models 101
but the they're all linked together if
you find a point where you think will
hang in a second am I going to really
appreciate me making this effort for me
tomorrow when I look back because if you
hadn't sent me that message a year ago
yes we wouldn't be made yeah doing all
of these cool things perfectly I
remember just looking I remember us sat
there thinking oh it's got that message
you know like they're judging me on but
three-second pauses ago showed message
that go out I say yeah [ __ ] it what's
coming back most look and I did it and
that's literally why we chatting right
now so yeah that's weird isn't it
asymmetry is going back to to the mental
models from the last episode talking
about that about the fact that yeah
actually side so huge yes in is almost
always going to result in that so talk
to the girl at the bar like and again a
concept from pickup artistry like assume
attraction is a really good way to go
about things because it just incurs to
offer when you assume they're attracted
to you yes always assume attraction
reason being that it will encourage you
into action as opposed to into inertia
which is the natural static yes
I think yeah if you just ask yourself
what's gonna bring about the best voice
for it end of the day I know it's weird
we were make Josh no no Garcia just got
out how's your girl getting up and
that's how he kept you up now he's three
and it gives you that frame good justify
for him Royce you guys I've got one that
you might not know have you heard of
third story the end of this no no no
maybe cool so
a third story you can imagine that in
any normal situation you have your point
of view my point of view but then you
would also have a third point of view
which would actually be from someone
outside of the situation looking at both
a lot of the time people will discuss
the fact that you want to see things
from someone else's perspective we don't
just need to see that because that might
not actually be the best place to see
this from the totally impartial observer
probably has the best view of both now
we spoke we spoke at length about how
much we love Jordan Peterson and some
Harris's approach to the beginning of
their debate together when they steal
man each other's arguments and is it
Warren Buffett who says he refuses to
have a position on anything on Charlie
Munger says refuses I think he says he
refused to have a position on anything
unless he can state the other side
better than the other side can basically
it's well it is a pity cause that his
iron discipline and the knack that
catches me a lot is where I have an
opinion on something and I'll keep
researching my side of the opinion keep
going over it and over and over the
other side and it kind of hold you
accountable and not chatting about
someone the other day I was having a
tomato movie strategizing at work and I
got a catch myself and I probably trying
on the one that was talking about a
certain market that we should look at
potentially invest in it and I go you
know what I actually think that's a
everybody was sign a guy I actually
don't know this subject well enough we
just want to sound clever don't win
there's so much man and I feel that we
talked about earlier of the benefit of
identifying probably as an idiot I only
buddy ever listening to this watching to
this please know that I am an imbecile
and I say that mainly for myself because
I we was talking about earlier when you
you recently and I'm sure people who
have heard the podcast a lot you talk a
lot about the benefits you got from
romwe and now you've you've done a bit
of a u-turn on that and the
we band you've got a bit of a u-turn on
that right and once you go out there
shouting out I am an EXOR I'm Republican
I am a Democrat I'm a smart person
I'm a whatever you want to do whenever
you have those labels it's them very
hard to once you've said it out loud to
everyone to then pivot and do a u-turn
often because people don't wanna be seen
as being a hypocrite but I admire people
so much more once they've been so gung
ho gung ho on something and they go the
other way people who've been in like
Scientology or the who the was the
Church in America that shouts at
soldiers funerals and they and they
leave and they go against the whole
family the ability to go against your
identity which I think's the hardest
thing to do he's so impressive which is
why I was identified an idiot because if
I identify as an idiot they were really
stupid stuff like the minimum or I play
old it's to be it to be anything that
there isn't it yeah like what is the
lowest grade entry that I can have
lowest barriers to entry idiot and I
think you know from from my perspective
this is something that I touched on
earlier with you know I haven't thought
this before but mercifully one of the
advantages of being a podcast host and
this is where Rogan gets it so correct
is that you don't actually ever end up
being the smartest person in the room
it's very rare that Rogen's the smartest
person in the room on whatever the topic
is maybe mm a sometimes maybe comedy
sometimes but even in that he might be
sacrum Francis and Garr knew me that
love he's a bit better MMA than you are
maybe know his knowledge maybe some new
ones have that Rogen's better or it
might be sacrum Brian Colin yeah well
who's the back comedian that's off a
debate such etc the advantage of being
someone who is in the middle of a lot of
other people and then presents that
information in the way that a podcast
host does is that you're never expected
to actually be the like paragon of
knowledge within an area you're just a
mere simulacrum representation of what
everyone else has been and that actually
allows you to hold much less concrete
views because everybody appreciates that
really all you are
if just little reflection of all the
people you've been exposed to but that's
all that anyone is the only difference
is when someone makes their identity
about it or brain Marcus when you talk
about how much you love polyamory look
at the comments on Aubrey Marcus's
breakup video with his wife Whitney
talking about how they're transitioning
their relationship and polyamory is
still the way to go and by the way if
you want to find out what happened to me
or Whitney's podcast this Wednesday on
blah blah blah and the people in the
comments going man
say how it is say that polyamory was
about a bad decision and say that you
breaking up not transitioning but those
guys have planted the flag in the ground
so hard and maybe they do still believe
this but when you've been so forthcoming
with talking about Whitney's off to go
and see her boyfriend in Texas to get
railed off some guy who's the 24 year
old stallion or some [ __ ] from Austin
yeah and you like right after you've
done that where'd you go from there it's
very difficult to allow that identity to
simmer back down again and for you to
actually say you know what it is might
have been wrong mmm
and there's a there's a mental model
that I've been thinking about for a
little bit for the self-serving bias
where you often have self-serving
reasons for your own actions and
behavior but when you're observing
others you excuse it as part of their
intrinsic intrinsic nature so I cut
someone up in traffic it's because I'm
in a rush someone else cuts me up in
traffic it's because there occurred yeah
I can see and that is a part due to a
different view perspective obviously the
fact that you can only see what's inside
your own head not someone else's but you
still do that it's called the
fundamental attribution error when you
were tribute others behaviors to their
motivations rather than to external
factors someone cuts you up in traffic
they might have been in a rush you say
[ __ ] but when it's about yourself you
always have the excuse self-serving bias
mmm yeah it's very very difficult to I
don't know did we speak about this last
time about the Warren Buffett who you'd
invest in who you just did we tried by
the last time
they remember that so yeah being able to
look at yourself as a as a third party
and I find it very very difficult if you
actually try I don't mean it's possible
to do that the way I find it most
usefully some look at other people look
at stuff that I like or my disagree I'm
not in terms of like a very judgmental
thing they need to stop doing that but
something I don't like personally and
then go when do I do that stuff or what
do I like I know how can I do more of
that stuff and actually you can almost
flip that weird bias that we have in our
head that we can see other people so
clearly by looking at other people look
at mistakes they're making and assume
you're making the mistake that they're
making the where actually is that and
try and punt it down that way I feel
that most these cognitive biases and
stuff rather than trying to fight them
which is what a lot of people seem to do
as soon as they get in that that whole
psychological rut like rabbit hole I've
been trying to fight them just use them
rights again if you realize okay
whatever ID that identify ours
it's going to be very very difficult for
me to break that rather than trying to
break that and going oh no I'm the guy
who cannot defy his identity no don't do
that when you just identify as what you
actually want to use and use those weird
little cognitive biases as a way forward
and I think that's the most that meta
mental model thing I father's rather
than trying to fix your own cognitive
biases of course you want to almost play
defense where you have going to be aware
of them you want to be aware of them
even though you probably can't be that
aware just use them like use certain
stuff realize that you're a shaved chimp
with millions of years of evolution and
you probably not gonna write rewrite the
programming yourself and yes go for the
highest ROI store yeah I think certainly
for instance we're talking about the
difficulty in retraining your identity
let's say whatever mental all want to
choose that to come up with why not say
I'm a happy person I'm a positive person
tell your friends if you tell your
friends I'm a happy person I'm a
positive person
yeah you're now socially accountable to
your mate hang on I thought you said
you're a happy person like positive
person oh [ __ ] that's something that I
want that is pretty much in defensively
a good idea
to do what where are you gonna go from
there I mean you want to continue to do
this so I spent I was there when I was
younger was fascinated by I discipline
and pushing myself and I found that I
could perform the only time I stood
habits for six months and could pick up
a new habit every single month we're
gonna have an app called habit share
where every month have various different
friends let's say okay I'm doing this
habit this month what you're gonna do
loser buys thinner at the end of the
month and habits sure they can see if
you check in that day you get push
notifications when they check in and
you're directly competing against one
another and all of a sudden I don't need
any will pardon me discipline I just
used the kilometer bias of over being
asked what other people are thinking
about me because again we're social
creatures rather than try and fight that
let's just use that I mean for the
listeners at home I was getting sent
screenshots of your habits share thing
and I'm not even on how it show oh yeah
you were showing it off to me yeah yeah
exactly [ __ ] it to me yeah so couple
of things that have been flirting around
recently so anchoring which is kind of a
little bit like first impressions matter
so where someone positive price to you
when you begin you then make everything
else relative to that there's a really
good example about economists pricing if
you heard this one no while so let me
run you through this
so in predictably irrational there's an
example from The Economist's pricing
strategy okay so three options to
subscribe you know this we're calling
this thing yeah three options to
subscribe web on these $59 print only is
a hundred and twenty-five dollars print
and web $125 yeah the split is web only
16% of people purchased print only 0%
print and web 84 percent now if you
remove the print and web option 68
percent instead of 16 by web only and 32
percent instead of 84 by print so by
adding in an option which means nothing
you anchor people's price in a different
way and this relates to something that
I'm gonna butcher the example so please
send me the proper study but the concept
is still solid
endoscopy x' were getting done on people
and they judged the relative amount of
discomfort someone was going to be in by
the amount of movement that's apparently
a fairly good metric for how much
discomfort is going to be more movement
equals more pain hmm
people went through this particular
endoscopy and were asked to rate their
overall pain afterwards now in one
iteration the pain was at a lower rate
let's call it four out of ten for almost
all but the very end rose up to around
about seven in another iteration the
experiment was actually extended so the
operation was longer but finished her
two instead of her sad hmm so overall
the second version second iteration of
this experiment was more total
discomfort it was longer I think there
was actually potentially like a five out
of ten throughout five or six throughout
said before but then dropped to a to ask
the patients to rate the relative pain
at the end of it overwhelmingly the
patients that finished a lower pain
score much fewer bad memories much lower
pain rating even though through every
objective measure it should have been
higher and there's a a quote I remember
seeing online that talks about if you
care about your child and they're going
through an operation that they can feel
this is something that you want to
happen because despite the fact that
through every objective measure your
child will go through more pain that
pain is transient but the memory is
forever and what they will remember will
be less pain and that to me is something
that I think about a lot final memories
or final impressions matter it's the
same way that first impressions matter
final impressions matter as well so
perfect example one of the guys that I'm
coaching some it recently got sent out
to some random country to go and train a
sales team literally two days notice
right now drop your life you've got go
out to
Istanbul somewhere okay cool
gets out there has three weeks of chaos
and he's speaking to me about four days
before he's gonna leave and he said what
do you think I should do and I was like
what personally I think you should do is
treat yourself as nicely as you can for
the final two days of your holiday find
the prettiest spot in Istanbul take
yourself out for a dinner find some good
music do something cool spend a little
bit of money buy yourself a nice pair of
trainers do something and then when you
come back you are going to lean your
memory towards all of the nice final
finishing moments that you had on that
trip and hopefully you'll help you to
forget that that's a really nice way to
help to either double down on a nice
experience or to mitigate a bad one is
to try and really finish it off with
something that's good that stand-up
comedy one-on-one you start off with
your second best joke and then you
finish with your best joke because that
is just what stand-up comedians always
do that makes a lot of sense um one
weird one which you've been thinking
about for a while and I'm not smart
enough to really flesh this one out but
we'll give it a go
crack it out oh mama which is orthogonal
fort which is when you come at something
from a completely different angle and
here's somebody else so this comes from
primarily Eric Weinstein and he talks
about two particular examples one which
is the I forgot the guy but he was on
the Japanese table table table tennis
team and he's one of the worst players
on that okay and I think I'm not sure
how many decades ago it was but he
decided to put foam on his back
everybody else was playing these wooden
bats and he puts foam as we know it now
like a modern table tennis and he would
destroy everyone and he beat everybody
around became the the best in the world
at the time and just from you got to
think he could have spent hours training
10,000 hours and probably still wouldn't
even make the team but instead sitting
at home and coming at it from a
completely different perspective and
you're putting foam on the box and then
nobody could compete
it's the same with you know the Fosbury
flop with the high jump everybody else
used to do it
face-first essentially jump over that
way race he came at it with this weird
angle and obviously people mocked him
for a while but it was a way more
efficient and effective way of doing it
and then there's a another great example
of the whole suitcase on wheels stuff
that suitcase on wheels didn't didn't
really exist till that'd be 80s or
whatever it was was a certain pilot that
launched it and you what I think
everybody was carrying around suitcases
nobody fought to pop [ __ ] suitcases
on wheels and and then one guy does it
and then that's the norm and I'm
fascinated by when you take her
perspective that often there's X or
there's Y there's X or Wilders the that
Robert Hanssen the evolutionary
biologist and physicist he chats about
this example with about immigration
which is obviously a very very hotly
contested topic one which is way above
my paygrade Madonna I don't really have
many opinions on but he chats about how
you have the Democrat side which is
obviously very very Pro immigration when
you have the Republican side which is
very very anti-immigration and they just
constantly this tug of war against each
other and instead of having this tug of
war game came coming on he says come on
it from an or yeah or famine or
perspective and you pull it from the
middle so for example what about if you
could every American had their
citizenship and it was worth X so let's
say it was worth $100,000 which meant
that they could sell it on to an
immigrant who wanted to come into the
country and they could move out that way
I mean all of a sudden you you fixed a
lot of the problems there and of course
that might not be the right or wrong
solution but all of a sudden isn't it
was a completely different vector
oh no on its side point to that I
podcasted with Robin Hanson just after
he released elephant in the brain and
asked him about orthogonal thinking and
he was really tired that day really but
he did never Cooley was over already
in question right what are you thinking
about orthogonal thing Keith and he was
[ __ ] he was like not really sure
about that 100k and talking about the
Fosbury flop and different ways things
to Lennox what one of the first people
may be the first but definitely one of
the first people to have a swimming
English Channel so he was a British
potentially army officer quite high up
in the Armed Forces and he did it
wearing sheepskin wool covered in goose
fat drinking whiskey because it would
keep him warm and he did the whole thing
breaststroke and when he was asked why
did you not do the front cross the front
crawl had been invented but recently
before so not very long before you know
his answer was it would be unbecoming of
a gentleman to put my head under the
water wow they did the whole English
Channel [ __ ] breasts I love that
story it would be unbecoming of a
gentleman to put my head in the water
Wow yes it's a different time it was a
bad time man when when men wouldn't put
their head in the water so on the the
orthogonal floor point one thing that's
to take an interest in it ties into you
know the peter thiel question of what do
you believe to be true that the rest of
the world disagrees with you on a very
very much contrarian question the i've
yet to hear anybody answer with real
yeah we've real video you actually have
it's creeped me out and i guess that's
the point of it because so socially so
here we go against the grain to the
listeners at home give us a tweet at
chris well x and at george underscore
underscore ma ck yeah and answer this
question as best you can what do you
believe to be true that the rest of the
world disagrees with you on so like a
good example at letter no often what
people will do and that's
scenario they'll go of the education
systems backwards or obviously years ago
they said we should legalize gay
marriage really if you actually asked
most of society they all actually agree
of these statements nowadays a good
example would have been 20 years ago
saying I actually think that the way the
college education systems going his back
was obviously ot of their done was proof
from proven right but trying to have all
for example in 2009 or 2008 when Satoshi
is made Bitcoin of saying oh I think
Bitcoin will be this new global digital
currency saying it now is but yeah no
[ __ ] Sherlock
they saying it maybe there would have
been a truly contrarian state and you
know it's contrarian when everybody
looks at you like you're an absolute
weirdo but it was the issue with that
though is that contrarians just go
either end of the of the spectrum there
either geniuses that remember throughout
history or they're writing their own
name on a wall and cheers yeah and
that's the issue with it then you don't
know who because there'll I'm definitely
nervous Nevada camp Navarro you talked
about it where he says that in San
Francisco you had to be polite to
everyone because that weird kid in a
hoodie might be the next Mark Zuckerberg
and with contrarians you you never know
that because if someone if somebody
would have been pitching Bitcoin to you
and it happened to me I watched him a
YouTube video and I've timed them
finishes on her probably nothing
and trying to pitch those there's
contrarian ideas that in hindsight
everyone will look back and go that was
so obvious yeah I was an absolute no
brainer but at the tech exact
realistically 99% of people listening or
people in general if they was around
when pre Galileo they would have
believed the world was the center of the
universe and if if anybody were try to
argue with them they would have thought
they were an idiot and I'm always trying
to think now what 50 years from now what
we think is ridiculous
and I also then try and think okay more
of a personal note what if I look back
on my behavior five years ago and find
it really cringey what Phi anyone net
might mean is from now will I find
cringy but anyone who doesn't look back
on their behavior five years ago
and find it cringe II know but the issue
see this is the iOS update on that of
course that's true but the thing is that
people forget is that what you're doing
right now
people you sorry you will find cringy
five years from now and you're almost
gonna comment from the friend man oh
[ __ ] there's going to be stuff that I'm
doing right now that's gonna be horrific
five years so now in the same way and
there's a large parts of society what
are we doing the fifty years from now
we're gonna go your grandkids know you
used to do that but you used to eat meat
again that's a contentious issue means
mean to one of the ones that I think
yeah particularly factory farming stuff
so trying to take a perspective of 50 to
100 years from a liar my favorite
examples is when they do a themed sort
of fancy dress party of us it's gonna be
a load of people like not chatting to
each other in a room like meet with
their [ __ ] but I post you just
texting each other I reckon that's what
this theme part is it gonna be like yeah
yeah because would be different
communication methods by learn it this
weird constant you have to you look like
the neuro-link stuff that you know must
do it this idea that we are okay and
this goes back to orthogonal for before
the whole neural link stuff came along
would you have thought the actually it
would make way more sense if I could
just a zap it from my brain to your
brain no you assumed I was good keyboard
this is the quickest way to do it yeah
but if you ever actually count how long
it takes you to text by a keyboard it's
so long but because everybody else is
doing it you assume it's the norm you
know that you're the other sheet you
follow the crowd and the one of the
favorite mental models that Tim tacked
up from Tim urban and it's the screen
saver on my laptop which is the [ __ ]
versus the chef have you heard of that
one no so a people often assume maybe a
cook and a chef for the same thing but
there's a fine fine difference is what
Tim urban argh
argues in the cook gets a recipe that's
been made and makes it mmm whereas a
chef afraid sees own recipe and that's
the difference between just following
okay texting is the quickest way I can
do this that's what cook does because
cooks just follow everyone else to do
whereas a chef thinks about it and goes
actually if I to design this recipe if I
had to get a message from my head to
Chrissy's head the quickest what would
it be and it be that she's thinking just
did it like that maybe it'd be quicker
than this the quicker this feel alike so
looking at it from a cooks perspective
in a chef's perspective and then it
comes back cook these things always loop
round in there then Tim Urban argues
that if you're a chef explore various
different recipes take a term test it
taste test it goes oh that's a bit [ __ ]
that's a bit rubbish and of course most
of the time you look like you're doing
worse than a cook because they've
already got a predefined route well when
a chef does win they win big and
ultimately you're playing a [ __ ] game
of ROI anyway it is just right man and I
was I've been searching around to try to
find this Court I finally found it
changing your habits often requires you
to change your tribe each tribe has a
set of shared experiences behaviors that
conform to the shared expectations are
attractive behaviors that conflict with
the shared expectations are unattractive
it's hard to go against the group James
clip tommy codes so what do you think
will be the will look back on 50 200
years I think you're right about that
I think the genes that lads a Newcastle
where I think they're probably they've
got to be pretty high up tight girl
genes I'm not sure man I mean the
defining characteristics right now you
don't know how quick things are going to
move like what's the paradigm gonna
shift on are we still going to be
looking at a political system similar to
the one that we've got now like is is
that really what's gonna continue is it
going to evolve or is it just going to
be more of the same we can presume the
technology will change but politics
actually hasn't seen any big dynamic
changes
shift in terms of the way that they're
deployed sort general public vote etc
etc like it it requires a large movement
to occur and because of the way that
those things happen they're often
unforeseen up until the point in which
they do happen like going the other way
like what was going to change from 50
years ago until in 50 years time
considering that now who could have
predicted Facebook who could have
predicted the Internet like you don't
know that these things are going to
happen and you just send a pulse
post Hawking the [ __ ] out of it if you
do mmm like a narrative fallacy where
yeah you retrospectively explain it and
you have this beautiful image in your
head um it's the guy called Brad Stone
who wrote the everyday store
it's about Amazon and Jeff Bezos Arsene
describes the story of Jeff Bezos and
what happened Amazon and apparently Jeff
was a bit reluctant to do it and when he
first sat down with Brad Stone he
basically said how are you going to
avoid the narrative fallacy how are you
gonna not make it look back that I had
this perfect plan to begin with and it
all only all executed exactly as I had
it planned and not retrospectively
ignore factors like a look and
experimentation and failure that went on
and it's yeah we always go back and just
tell ourselves a story before we finish
I wouldn't it if you wanted to give us a
short break down on your favorite blog
post of all time ah interesting and I do
it yeah that's dear cool this will be
linked in these show notes below it's
one of the worst titles a thisvery
clickbait e but i think the actual
content of it is i mean it's it's harsh
truths to make you a better person or
along those lines I think it's David
Wong who wrote it it is
and he has you do I mean you might go
back up at me
so the block-post basically talks that
the synopsis of it is you are what you
can present to society and societies
only bothered in what it can get from
you that's the main truth and the first
example is imagine that you're walking
on the street with a loved one and a car
comes along hits your lover they're
lying on the floor bleeding and you're
screaming for someone who has some
medical experience a person comes over
and kneels down next to them and you ask
them if you're laughing already
and you ask them up fantastic are you a
doctor
this person turns to you and starts
telling you about how they're a good
father how they're always trustworthy
and how they're never late for work and
you go hang on a second I didn't I
didn't ask you about that what I said
was do you have some medical experience
and this person begins to get a little
bit irritated now they say well no
you're not listening to me I'm a very
good person and I always I always stick
to my promises and I'm always true to my
virtue and my kids really love me and
you say he's screaming at them look I do
not care about your values or your
virtues tell me whether or not you can
save my dying partner on the street and
the analogy that he uses is society is
the dying man on the street and you are
the person standing over them holding a
penknife in a desperate attempt to try
and bring them back to life all that
society is concerned about is what you
can produce running elaborate yeah I
think going that's poor graphics which
we've started off with here's I think he
used to be on people ycs walls or his
own walls which is make something people
want because he would have so many young
entrepreneurs he would come through with
these ideas of how they're gonna change
the world and they would always fail
that fundamental thing if they're not
making something that people want like
nobody actually wants his idea but look
at any ideas I've had or friends of
harlots the reason why it often fails is
because they've sort of kept them cell
their own bubble and they've not
actually gone and found out if this is
actually what people want I mean again
you almost got apply that same thing to
yourself instead of just there's a great
clip from Glengarry Glen Ross I think it
is by Alec Baldwin I think he's only at
8 9 minutes and he won an Oscar for that
performance and he just says nice guy I
don't give a [ __ ] go home and play with
your kids and that sounds brutal it
sounds horrific but it's almost
objective of somebody who's never met
you before looking at your objects with
you going what can you do for me and
people see that as a very very almost a
dark and negative world I actually think
it's it's the way we operate we're
always constantly looking at making
society better and the reason why I
always use the analogy that that sale
that sorry networking in particular
again if you talk about contrarian
opinions and this is a bit nuanced but
networking can be largely I think
overrated by a certain sort of
individual and who very very cat-like
nice and charismatic and can track a
good game and it's read a few books but
there's no substance to anything they've
ever they've ever done there's nothing
on their actual rap sheet I've got I can
I can code this or I know how to build a
sales team like this or I've achieved
this many things that CrossFit this week
or whatever it is right we always just
want to be liked for being a nice guy
but everyone's probably the next
ceremony ship again isn't it going back
to to the Navy SEALs stuff another great
point that the hoof one comes up with in
that article is where he talks about
people believing that they deserve a
good partner mmm they say well look how
trustworthy I am and I'm really caring
and a you know I've got a good job and
I've got stable income and this
and his in the blog post he says so
[ __ ] what that is what you need to
get you through the door and there is a
guy out there who has everything you
have and we can play the [ __ ] guitar
like David you you got it man like there
is a guy out there who has every talent
that you have and he can play the
[ __ ] guitar mmm how are you going to
compete with the man that can play the
guitar I I think you are right it isn't
baby was he great easy and it has a
nuanced point in there he says that what
you do or what you've done is actually a
real reflection of who you are she can
remain trace if who you are is all you
are you're not produce anything then
naturally it wasn't what you are that's
a little bollocks right what you produce
she's ultimately a reflection of what
your your thoughts are is that home
slightly we're thing I love if
somebody's let's say there's a hurricane
that's gone on I'll pray for those
people of course I think that a lot of
people who do that I'm trying to do
something funny do something good but
that's you cannot if you actually do
something as well now that's that's
where the real power is well of course
you can pray in there at the same time
but what we've saying earlier on about
the path of least resistance about
inertia as opposed to movement like you
are right I think it's it's not a very
softly softly approach I bet if some of
the Navy SEALs read that blog post I bet
they would agree with it guys that are
forced into action guys that have to do
things first it's not very sentimental
way to view things but I would struggle
to see how looking at output first what
are the things what are the explicit
tangible objective measures by which
I've represented my value in the real
world if you use those I struggle to see
how life comes at you with things that
you're going to be unprepared for or at
least I think you
yourself the best chance of being robust
or any fragile enough to deal with them
because we can all edit our Instagram
photos to look like successful
entrepreneurs but your P&L sheet is what
actually matters right and that's that's
the difference and I guess I didn't
essence what Royce gone Royce god I
guess that's a good way to to end on
just just again there's a great bit as
well similar to the Royce core bit of
them you've seen the Bill Hicks bit it's
just a riot it's a very very similar to
the Royce core of where you can end up
going down lots of different rabbit
holes and thinking very very deeply
about stuff but once you realize we've
got a very very limited time on this
earth and a hundred years from now no
one will probably remember your name
yeah man it's been fantastic again I
hope that everyone that has chindan has
enjoyed it mental models one or two we
have finished you got me I'm a caveman
for smilk okay and you know all the way
from London Newcastle to come in record
a podcast where people gonna find you
George
underscore M ACK on Twitter I'm gonna
force them to tweet at you so that
you're forced to reply because it's too
polite to not reply to people but you're
not on Twitter at the moment you too
busy working
fitting 200 our works wheels into one
here and 100 oh we just avoided the
carpet store on their time good man
thank you very much for tuning in please
like share subscribe all that good stuff
I do appreciate every time you do at
Chris relax on all social media if
you've got any questions
George underscore underscore plaque on
Twitter as well thank you very much man
I peace
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you